[Musica]
buon pomeriggio e grazie dell'invito mi
chiamo anna spertini sono un'insegnante
segno ai bambini e agli adolescenti e ho
trascorso gli ultimi cinque mesi della
mia vita a studiare le microespressioni
facciali e le emozioni ad esse correlate
ecco questa per esempio è un espressione
di gioia sincera
questa invece l'espressione che fanno i
miei conoscenti quando dico loro come ho
trascorso l'estate c'è un certo disagio
e anche una certa impressione perché
effettivamente le microespressioni
facciali sono spesso correlate e
associati allo smascheramento delle
menzogne
questo anche grazie a un telefilm di
qualche anno fa ma non sanno le persone
che applicando queste tecniche a un
altro settore come quello didattico
siamo in grado di ottenere una
comunicazione maggiore con gli studenti
e anche una maggiore consapevolezza di
se stessi sono anche una mamma mio
figlio si chiama alessandro a 9 anni
studia il violino con il metodo suzuki
il metodo suzuki è un metodo innovativo
nell'insegnamento della musica
universalmente riconosciuto è chiamato
anche metodo della lingua madre fu
creato nel secolo scorso da shinichi
suzuki che è un violinista insegnante
giapponese e la fondano il fondamento
principale di questo metodo è che tutti
possono apprendere dal loro ambiente
quindi quando crei l'ambiente giusto e
stimolante stimoli anche le stesse
situazioni nello studente e così
favorisce l'apprendimento condizione
essenziale del metodo suzuki e alla
partecipazione di almeno un genitore nel
percorso di studio e infatti il successo
di ogni programma suzuki sta proprio
nella buona qualità di questo cosiddetto
triangolo suzuki che è formato dalla
relazione di collaborazione tra
l'insegnante genitore e bambino
ecco questa è una classe di violino
la scuola suzuki di siena il maestro di
violino di mio figlio si chiama alessio
natuzzi in via solitamente diverse email
ai genitori per supportarli nel loro
ruolo di genitori e suzuki e per aiutare
i loro figli appunto nell'apprendimento
del violino a casa la primavera scorsa
alessio invia una mail a tutti i
genitori che tra le altre cose contiene
un link al sito web di paul ekman paul
ekman è un ricercatore che ha dedicato
tutta la sua vita alla ricerca delle
microespressioni facciali e delle
emozioni ad esse correlate vado a
visitare il sito web e vedo subito che
all'interno c'è una grandissima quantità
di informazioni interessanti non solo
per il lavoro che svolgo ma anche come
mamma per aiutare mio figlio con lo
studio del violino
il materiale è tantissimo ed è anche
abbastanza costoso quindi chiedo ad
alessio se è possibile condividere la
spesa alessi accetta e così condividiamo
anche i momenti di studio
trascorriamo l'inter estate a studiare e
arriviamo a fine estate che riusciamo a
conseguire il fax coders notifica questo
è un certificato che viene solitamente
conseguito da persone che poi vanno a
collaborare come esperti con la polizia
o con il tribunale ma noi vogliamo
applicarlo alla didattica perché siamo
convinti che potrà darci risultati
sorprendenti e in questo frangente
conosco anche meglio alessio conosco
alcuni dettagli della sua vita e come
arrivato a siena e scopro così che come
paul ekman ha dedicato tutta la sua vita
allo studio delle microespressioni
facciali alesse ha dedicato tutta la sua
vita non soltanto alla musica e al
violino ma anche alla ricerca di un
metodo didattico unico nel suo genere
immaginateli infatti di prendere diversi
strumenti e tecniche di comunicazione
usate solitamente in settori di nicchia
e di applicarli alla didattica
l'effetto è immediato tra insegnanti e
studenti si crea una comunicazione
un'empatia profonda
i risultati vengono raggiunti in tempi
molto più rapidi e con
un benessere di fondo stabile il maestro
alessio ma così è convinto che sia
possibile tramite l'utilizzo di diversi
metodi come il metodo suzuki il mental
training line alpi coaching il metodo
feldenkrais sella profile riuscire a
ottenere una situazione per la quale nel
momento della performance e quindi del
concerto dell'esecuzione
il bambino sia in una situazione di zero
stress e quindi benessere di fondo
stabili molte università straniere e
italiane si sono rivelate interessate
alla ricerca di alessio
tra queste anche royal college di londra
e ovviamente anche il paul ekman group
che ci ha donato parte del materiale di
studio e allora il passaggio è come
facciamo per definire il livello di
stress nei bambini
esiste un test semplice affidabile che
si chiama test del cortisolo salivare
consiste nel prelevare un piccolo
campione di saliva dal soggetto nel
momento della performance quindi in
questo caso del concerto per misurare
appunto la quantità di cortisolo quando
questo ormone che viene prodotto dalle
ghiandole surrenali è presente in
quantità elevata indica una condizione
di stress
alessio na cucci nei suoi anni di
esperienza ha applicato proprio questo
metodo su tanti bambini i suoi studenti
e ha visto che effettivamente si può
applicare si può fare ei risultati ci
sono
io sono una testimonianza entusiasta di
questo perché ho visto che mio figlio
soltanto dopo due anni di studio del
violino è ora in grado di suonare a
memoria
più di cinquanta pezzi tra cui anche
pezzi molto complessi e quindi pensate
un po come potrebbe essere applicare un
metodo di questo genere anche ad altre
materie tipo la matematica la storia le
lingue straniere avremmo moda finalmente
di dare la possibilità ai nostri figli
di trarre il massimo vantaggio da questo
aspetto dell'apprendimento che li
accompagnerà per tutta la loro
vita e arriviamo così al espressione di
gioia sincera che vi ho mostrato
all'inizio
immaginatevi i vostri figli felici di
imparare e fortemente motivati a farlo
immaginatevi anche la vostra di felicità
quando realizzerete ciò che avete fatto
per loro grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]